okay then let me thank the invite her
that's all the organizers for inviting
me to be here and very happy that
reinforcement learning theory and
skyping interested to work won't even be
precise and also I don't know if you are
aware of this so there will be flu
semester program on reinforcement
learning theory in the next fall here
it's a necessity so hopefully we can
together make a lot of progress okay so
I'm gonna talk about again really
important learning and it stays in
theory and I'll focus on RL in future
space and the conversation so nan
already made a very nice introduction so
he has laid the basic won't work so I
don't have to repeat the background
again so basically we we all know that
so RL has been very successful
empirically with computer games SARS ago
I mean simple hairy games like a mágico
like humanoid robots and only with
certain scenarios with self-driving cars
okay so chemically we know that RL is
getting more and more powerful in real
life but however if we look at all these
applications so we realize that in
computer games or in certain simulated
robotic applications or is there any
commercial applications so basically the
accessibility to theta is unlimited in
games basically usually we don't talk
about data in games but what we do like
self play in earth ago really this are
our ism the learning algorithm is
generating data introductions so
essentially one can generate even amount
of data in these applications and then
solving a problem becomes computation
okay but however let's consider other
scenarios where we cannot do RL
efficiently yes yet Kodomo if we wanna
use optimization are out to figure out
the best clinical treatment
apparently I wouldn't myself trust an RL
algorithm at his current stage because
for every particular scenario a very
particular condition and particular
group of patients the amount of theta
available might be quite limited and all
the practical decisions in your life are
made based on domain expertise and
similarly if we understand how
single-cell evolves so this needs to one
has one can only understand that by
collecting actual data in a web map an
interaction of data is very costly and
similarly if we talk about dream formal
learning for clinical trials then each
data point could be a human life so they
are definitely very expensive this is
completely different from the game
settings
okay so what are basic there are your
questions URL so first if we just think
about video machine learning the first
ever question would care about this well
I want to learn a classifier where I
want to learn our predictor and I have
some information about it so how many
data points do I need so similarly you
reinforcement learning a very basic
question is suppose that I want to get a
good policy maybe a 90% efficient policy
or maybe just 50% maybe 50% efficient is
good enough to beat the human channels
okay suppose that that's what I want
how many decimals are needed and how do
we use the samples to and a related and
potentially harder problem is suppose
that we want to learn to control a
process on the fly then how much regret
do we have to pay and there are strongly
related problems okay so just to recap
the model of reinforcement learning so
let's look at the very basic tabular
case for Markoff these intervals us so
I'll just introduce my own or patients
so I call the set of possible States as
asked for state space and assess for
possible actions we called a and at
every state upon assigning an action
there is a reward function which could
also be random and also the system is
going to evolve according to some
transition probability law and II
reinforcement learning we do not know
the transition probably hero or the
system under state actions and
optimization formulation is that we want
to find a policy by policy the window
will open am a team from the state the
space of states to the space of actions
in order to maximize the cumulative
return of the Markov decision process
what this policy pipe is implemented
okay so sometimes we call this basic
problem called tabular MVP I have a room
in that visit here we have a bunch of
space but we have no other knowledge
about the connection among the state
space so we don't have any structure
knowledge this is a terrorist
okay so let's how about some Boca back
to you first so what does a sample mean
so this is attachment so by one sample
we mean that suppose that we have one
state of the game pages and then maybe
we choose an action with our them
through the action and the game is going
to evolve with some randomness and also
it's going to be generating our reward
at this transition and they would look
at this triple-eight state actually
reward and state triplet okay how does
triple it to be one some hope for our
out okay
so the question is how many of those
triplets
do we need at least in order to get an
absolute optimal policy
okay so those are the sharpest results
that I am aware of the first the
information through a limit to us okay
for this I'm considering the simplified
case when every word is a known function
but in more generally speaking the
complexity of estimating the word is
much less than a convexity per aspera
model so it doesn't matter if we know
the rewards were not okay so if we're
making thrival limits as this which was
established by a group of folks at
deepmind so basically we know the
information limit to get an optimal
option policy was a reasonable
probability this is the number of sample
that we need each some boys are triple
eight so there's this number of states
multiplied was number of actions that's
basically the total possibility the
total number of possibilities okay and
this view is actually pretty important
the cube exam this loop is pretty
magical here and a lot of efforts have
been put into trying to reduce assemble
complexity of algorithms to reach that
cubic okay so the sharpest always and
we're aware of i can actually achieve
some oakum has a lower bound so we had a
result from last year and also recently
I believe Alec showed that it's also
possible to achieve this result under
certain conditions using a similar
method okay so in short it has already
known that how to achieve the same
igniting lower bound being wasn't
learning in the tabular case we don't
answer
and to get to this we need to do a lot
of things like variance reduction like
understanding our accumulation and the
across equations and also how to
understand the total variance
accumulation for America process by
putting everything together it's
possible to achieve the lower back and
also in terms of regret there have been
a lot of work on regret for RL for
example show that 4-h horizon MDP so by
doing something about doing a variant of
Q learning one can achieve this regret
although this is not optimal we believe
may be the optimal should be just linear
in age but this is something no one has
been able to do so it's a high openness
Craiova okay so basically at least in
terms of these contractors the size the
sizes of theta actions faces we already
know they're sharpest to do complexity
and also for regret we are pretty good
why it should be linear in each because
the other ones are gamma cute isn't that
age oh so this is because this absalom
error is for a value on the order of 1
over 1 minus gamma but this is regret so
1 so one order of magnitude is absorbed
into the regret itself
setting your slave
depends on whether still traditional
stationary and if it's stationary is H
and if it's non stationary like whether
T is number of episodes vs. okay so
basically there's our problem so we all
know we sort of know the sharp and the
close to sharp someone contacts any
regrets but we don't like those results
because ask the safe space is too big so
let's just look at this
so suppose that's the state we are
working with see that they are D
dimensional vectors so maybe in a simple
problem like mounting car so it's I
think it's three or four dimensional
like velocity on positions and maybe
acceleration so it's a multi dimensional
vector to characterize the physical
state of the process right if our input
are your pixel images the dimension is
going to be the liberal pixels in the
images okay so say that we don't have
any structure knowledge so we just do
vanilla tabular MVP and then we just do
vanilla disquisition then the state
space is basically going to be true to
thee you can also look like the size of
the policy space the size of the policy
space is going to be number of actions
to the ass because we have freedom to
choose any action at any state and even
if we take log of the policy space we
still get dependents on earth and its
financial dimension of the state vectors
Tollett so apparently this is pretty
pessimistic
okay so now let's look at where does
dimensionality show up in the bellman
equation so Velma equation is like the
KKT condition is the automatic condition
for optimal control and America
theatergoers so this is the average
reward Val my question and she's the
average of we're here because it's
cleaner
so basically solving the Markov decision
process it's equivalent to finding the
solution to this high dimensional the
nonlinear systems amenity for every
single state ask we need to make a
decision a to maximize our immediate
return and future accumulate returns
this maximization over a applies to
every single state every single state so
we have a high dimensional nonlinear
equation so another way to look at
verses
Felmy equation actually has an
equivalent minimax formulation so one
can try it so this is those that there
will be an interesting exercise start
here first show that this equal is
equivalent to a linear program and the
linear program has a primal dual
population and the problem of omission
is nicer to work was in which the primal
variable is over the space of value
functions and the dual variable is over
the space of I would say long-run
frequency distributions or in this
average or case just stationary state
action distribution so we have to
allocate between value functions and
long-run distributions okay so if you
look at this this this should be
something that will that's more familiar
to have right now it's like an empirical
risk minimization problem so we have
strong duality and smoothness and the
linearity here
so fundamentally bellman equation is
about a high dimensional linear program
which is s times a times s so in the
case when we have continuous state
problems this is essentially infinite
dimensionality okay
so now let's think about the meant
reduction so in practice people use
feature maps so feature maps is a
popular approach for them introduction
of RL I mean way before deep learning
was used in RL well I believe in 1990s
people can already soft caches pretty
well using 22 features but Hatcher is a
very simple game okay so by features
with me likes suppose that this is the
fate of Patras they will look at this
and try to come up with features maybe
the top one features is going to be
height of the the wall and the talk to
feature may be like the number of hosts
on the top level so there are a bunch of
hand-picked features okay so suppose
that we have 22 hand-picked features you
know what people do is they can try to
map every single state into our 22
dimensional feature back and hopefully
that helps okay so the basic idea here
is now in order to ask me the high
dimensional model functions to make it
work in a computer program one can use a
linear model to present the high
dimensional value function for a
particular policy so everything can be
computed in the linear in a simpler
linear space so suppose that we try to
compute the value of the state and we
know the weights w1 w2 w3 and then we
simply calculate the weighted
combination and this is a proxy to the
value function and can be used in
research or like microvessels so this
has been used for a long time in
reinforcement learning or in approximate
dynamic programming before the use of
people
okay and apparently being a model has a
lot of limitations as now already
mentioned so okay but however I want to
argue that linear models are the most
basic models for understanding the
theory and the mathematics
so that's the focus of my talk so one
way to think about the memory dr. Balian
Cruz in the following we have already
seen that spell my equation is high
dimensional nonlinear but to make it
more compatible to erm we can think
about this as a minimax problem now we
have a Lagrangian function which is
linear in primal value function and two
distributions okay and also we have
unknown transition probability model
here which can be replaced by impure
samples and we are working with our
problem with high dimensional
premise-based and hydrate reduce phase
and now if we have modeling assumptions
we can restrict our search space to our
model classes and a simple thing to do
is to replace a sewage street the search
space into linear subspace spanned by
the features and if we do that we can
reduce bellman equation into something
pretty small and moderate so one can
yeah right we've only that right so I'm
hi I'm Anna I'm not showing the
algorithm but the basic idea is PA in
the Lagrangian is not known but each
sample gives me a noisy version of the
partial gradient so we can do a
stochastic promoter quit and type
message to solve it that's actually one
of our earlier paper and with my cross
Rd home and we can show that well by
doing this promoter policy gradient
method using one sample a time we don't
need to know the piece but one can fund
absolute policy using the sample size
this is number of say features times
number
and we had another recent results on
q-learning
and we made it sample option option as
well so again we got number of safe
features a number of action features and
cubic okene cubic was the hardest thing
and this matches the information
transforming Explorer box so just just
to make sure the right page here this is
still in the generator market
exploration not not yet okay yeah so at
least in this very I was a very basic
sighting of generate models we know how
to figure out the absolute optimal
policy using the minimal sample size and
so we can reduce pieszecki big ass to
number of state action features so
that's the first message okay so hope
Jonathan models are not practical enough
so you want to be better than that so
what do you mean by general model so
johnniemorrow means that I have a
perfect simulator of the game or of the
system and we can basically use the
January model to avoid this issue of
exploration so that we can basically
draw some more transitions from any pre
specified state action pairs so which is
reasonable if we have we actually have a
simulator of the system and also to get
sample optimal algorithms the act hours
and actually need to generate basically
the same number of sample samples per
each state or per each few actions or
representative states to make sure that
we basically have them all we have the
the automated policy well-controlled
about every direction okay Howard this
is not practical if we not uniformly
frequently visit the samples are the
safest
do not let's consider another scenario
which has a lot more complications now
we want to learn on the fly
see that okay we have an H horizon
control problem or we have an H harden
thing so we know that the game is going
to end in H time steps
Tyler we cannot some home from any
intermediate state of a game we have to
play from the very start use using
certain policy to the end of a game and
then we can play again okay so we want
to make sure that the learning algorithm
have to actually act in the real world
and it has to act well act in real time
while making observations and it's the
hours and could update its control
policy during the learning period and
what was puppet but what's more
complicated is that in this action in
the real world setting it's not
guarantee that we can visit all states
frequently enough hours now designing
that way there is possible that there's
a particular healing stage and we just
never get a chance to visit it okay
and in this idea we care about the
regret for apostolic RL so the the
regret is defined very naturally by
looking at the difference between the
optimal value function from the initial
state as a thorough and the actual
rewards we collect in one episode and
then we take the sum of this per episode
regret so with some across older and
episodes and so some challenges here is
that well if we pray I can hear again so
if we do something wrong on the first
time step and maybe we will just end up
in a bad absorbing States and we never
learn in the next h plus 1 sorry h minus
1 for sex and also in terms of our
learning then we have a lot of data
dependency because for each episode the
transitions for the sample treatment
sample to the littlest are generated by
the same system using the same policy
and also my policy come from my previous
experiences so there's dependency
everywhere and if we try to find a naive
reduction to just murder and bandit what
do you happiness basically a naive
reduction means that every policy could
be one arm and then we have number of
arms that is exponential we have a
number of arms that is exponential in
I mean exponential in age in horrible
okay okay now let's try to consider RL
in our learning with features there
suppose I were given the feature Maps so
I already explained what our feature
maps so each state can be met
it can be mapped into a vector okay and
I need to map state actions join to the
into a feature map so if we have
separate state feature and separate
action feature we can take their
products and so now whenever I have a
state action state triple-eight I'm
going to map it into a feature vector
for state action and another feature
vector for state so maybe originally my
states and actions are rapid or images
but after this Magon they should be
lower dimensional vectors okay and let's
look at one possible model for reducing
the demand analogy or out let's try to
work with the transition kernel or the
transition probability matrix so as we
have seen in the bellman equation all
the complication comes from the fact
that this is a complicated function
which dimension as times a and s okay
what if it admits a simpler lower
dimensional decomposition structure
maybe it's low rack okay so we make the
assumption that the transition kernel
can be decomposed using the state action
feature and the safe feature and then
there exists a matrix here which we do
not know
so let's see does this buy us anything
so while I wonder so how does this
decomposition follow on the transition
colonel relates to using features or
value function approximation so one can
show that actually this decomposition is
equivalent to using linear model for
value function approximation if there
are zero bellman error okay so
essentially I'm trying to say that
low-dimensional some general value
function has to come from low
dimensional assumption of the transition
model otherwise why would there be nicer
simple structure of all that it
functions okay can i connect I said real
quick clarification of that last point
so here you are you simply saying that
if I want to represent for example just
the optimal value function with zero
error in with a linear approximator this
this is equivalent to having some no
this equivalence is about approximating
value function on the entire solution
path of policy improvement was 0 bellman
error okay so that's a stronger it's not
only about optimal battle the
intervening value functions and
constructing have to have exact
representations that right and also I'm
not making assumption on the word
function if the real word function has
even lower dimensional structure as
possible that we can do even better so
we call governor here is
I think it would be in trouble sometimes
call that they can care about my hair
right so this is basically the kind of
like the closeness assumption that I was
talking about there nation of that
closeness exactly actually if the bell
marrow is not there oh there could be we
could be in a lot of troubles okay that
get back to that later okay let's let's
first live in a similar world assuming
that the matrix accommodation model is
perfect and okay so now let's see what
we can do you suppose how we are playing
this game and we are at the beginning of
the impasse was episode I suppose that
we have already collected a lot of
trajectories and somehow so far and for
each triplet that we have collected
we're going to map them into a five
actor and a pizzelle vector and now I
want to simply ask mate there's lower
dimensional matrix that parameterize the
transition kernel so to do that we can
simply do a question so this is just a
version of matrix regression with a
reader analyzer
so okay can we can we just do regression
on the sample transitions to Assam ate
the traveler and apparently we care
about regret right so it's very easy to
see that in only in any other learning
scenario if we simply do the impure go
athletes and do it really though here we
are not going to do well inspiration so
we can borrow ideas from linear bandit
can we use spending ideas to help
exploration
so we can first try to construct a
confidence ball
I run the transition core matrix that we
admitted from previous trajectories and
i am omitting a lot of details here this
a is really just a covariance matrix
from half circles and so we can control
the confidence bow in a way that one can
show that with high probability the
ground truth transition curve always
belongs to the sequence of confidence
votes and now when we do Fellman updates
we are going to do a version of Velma
updates that is optimistic in
consideration of uncertainty in the
confidence so every time we try to
if I am Mesa max over a somewhere so
every time we try to do Belma updates
we're supposed to have the transition
matrix here but we replace it was the of
the most optimistic automated transition
matrix from the confidence fall so we're
taking max over core matrix from the
bottom okay and hopefully every time we
are gagging a q value that is higher
than the actual QX so you know doing
anything introducing any constraints to
make sure this is a these correspond to
transition probabilities just regression
so it's really about just about
regression to athlete the transition
matrix and also using analyzing the
uncertainty in regression to do an
optimizing a version of q function
ethics okay and finally we have computed
new set of Q functions and the next time
when we actually play this game we're
going to simply use our optimistic Q
functions we really and because every
time we do this max overconfidence ball
we can make sure that we are already
adding the bona functions so that the Q
functions we are have computed are going
to encourage exploration
so under a bunch of conditions which I'm
hiding here one can show that now we
have a regret found so they'll regret
for this algorithm in terms of time
steps not episode yes the mention of
Fisher Space Age quadratic and squared
of T so we believe that this happens to
be the first to regret bounds for
reading formal learning that is
polynomial in Fisher dimension and also
in horizon H and it's definitely
independent of s so hopefully it will
lead to a more practical algorithm and
when I asked whether this is me max out
chemo so I don't have a minimax lower
bound specifically for this problem but
if we borrow our knowledge is from
tabular reinforcement learning and also
from linear bandit then we should
roughly know that the linear dependence
on B is optimal the new Penny's RH is
definitely not optimal probably should
be square root of H and also squirt the
sruthi is optimal so are you familiar
with this so you seen and you seen and
Gergely have this
I think this preprint that's been
sitting on archive since 2014 or
something where they're basically
assuming that there are transitions and
rewards are both linear and they are
basically again doing exactly this
linear bandit type estimation maybe with
optimistic linear programming instead of
is that the one cause something like
continuous they can be yeah that's a
different setting right let's is that
different it's similar because there's
also a linear regression couple in it
but I think it's it's not the same okay
yeah I just
I was curious a lot of their differences
because I don't have anything is it's
time
the difference like there's a point coin
toss whether you do it every time step
versus you do it
like one time for the entire no there's
another one using this feature dimension
D but that one is exponential in age but
that's probably not the one you are
talking about okay so what my what my
again argue that the decomposition
structure is too strong essentially we
are assuming a pragmatic model for the
transition matrix okay so let's try to
relax it up relax it a little bit so
what is I do have five features for
state actions but however I'm going to
relax plus I the right feature space to
be just at the identity map so assuming
that I have feature functions Phi that
can characterize the left singular space
of the transition and I don't make any
assumption are the right similar space
so now this becomes a non magic model
okay
okay so in this case actually Mitch the
the algorithm I showed you has a cool
form update so we really have to
maximize over a bowl of even a three
dimensional or high dimensional matrices
but we can actually write a bonus
function expression for school and our
rhythm still works and however in this
case because we are losing lower
dimensional structure on the right hand
side and this space is going to be the
space to be multiplied with the net next
time step random function so somehow in
analysis we'll lose a square root in the
dependence on thee and I don't know
whether this is optimal or maybe
so next so the the method I just
explained can be naturally extended to
the kernel six so now suppose that I'm
giving a kernel function to describe the
state action space but I don't have
explicit Fisher Maps so actually
meaningful learning in kernel space has
been previously explored in pretty
different settings without much the
right no guarantees but kernels do
present a very flexible framework and
they can be used to interpret neural
networks as well so I we thought that
would be nice to have a kernel
plantation so now the Assumption changes
to that we are going to assume that the
left and the right space for the
transition kernel can be represent can
be embedded by given our caches and in
this case the algorithm actually has a
equivalent chronology ssin which you
don't have to read and we want to show
that now the regret depends on basically
the kernel norm the Hilbert space norm
of the unknown transition probability
matrix and also it depends on some
effective dimension of the kernel is
okay some like luck determined matrixes
over a worst-case beta distribution
so it's essentially the-- in the
original case or in this case it's like
nice okay so now we have seen that in
the very basic simulation case one can
achieve good sample capacity and also in
the case when we believe that transition
model has this accommodation again one
can get good regret hopefully depending
linearly on dimensional features how
we're using features were even from
learning well there are four stand
against so first the reason that we do
this research is we want to understand
the theory of RL and linear models are a
very basic model to study and it also
while we do analysis or analysis has a
very deep connection to just the do
regression so I think this is a very
important observation and also to do it
in this regression and the upper
confidence type of methods well it's
relatively easy to implement by easy to
implement I mean that there are not many
parameters to tune but however using
linear models have a lot of like pelada
logical pathological problems so forth
and also the approach I just described
heavily rely on the fact that we
actually have good for even person
perfect features and well I don't have
good perfect features what could happen
if policy equation might lead to our
oscillating features or oscillating
policies and shadowing effects so this
is a plot I borrow from Perseus book so
if the feature space cannot fully
correct rise the bellman updates what
could happen is there might be different
regimes and policy situation will just
these two oscillating policies because
the features are not good enough
approximating the value functions in the
correct space okay and now and also
linear models are definitely not as rich
as nonlinear models so is there there's
a gap that we hope to bridge and also
it's not very surprising that while we
do have good features the problem
becomes lower dimensional right this is
like a basic basic intuition from
Statistics and what if we don't know
good features so there have been a lot
of work in this domain car-like state
representation learning mostly empirical
and also I think some do and the men
they have this nice work on how to do
latent state encoding during online
reinforcement learning in the tabular
case so I think this is an interesting
problem and I hope to discuss with you
what can be done in this domain so what
could be good state features I already
explained that our assumption was that
the transition transition matrix can be
represented in using lower dimensional
subspace or this is just stationary
Markov chain no decision so if we look
at the value function of stationary
Markov process naturally this is one
definition of value function and now if
we believe that the transition system
that we are working with it's actually
not that complicated we might be working
with objects or images but they response
to lower dimensional hidden physical
states so in those cases we're willing
to assume that this transition matrix
will transition her no which we don't
know has approximately lower rank
structures maybe it has such a
decomposition was people here being
something much smaller
so under this low round consumption then
one can show that both the value
function and also the invariant measure
lie in low dimensional spaces so if we
want to find good features I think the
proposal is to directly look at
principal components of the transition
regime
so we try to do something in this domain
but without the control part we just
look at time series data and we try to
figure or try to ask me the spectral
decomposition the left and the right
principal components of the traditional
surely from data and again this can be
formulated into an optimization problem
and our goal is to map a complicated
state into a lower dimensional vector to
preserve the transition dynamics so I'm
going to go over this quickly so the
basic idea is the following suppose that
where video was a higher dimension of
ham service but we're given a kernel
space tool and as we believe that a
kernel space is relevant to the
transition dynamics of the time series
and then we'll conclude with some a
summation so what we do is we try to
open up the kernel space by
approximating it using random thousand
features so first we have something that
can be computed in common have
reservations and yes we can athlete a
projection of the transition kernel from
data and then the projection matrix can
be again open up using spectral
decomposition to get a lower dimensional
map so we call this like a kernel eyes
diffusion map as matter so what can be
done this we hope to capture information
in the conditional transition in the
conditional density for a particular
state and after this we can map it into
a lower dimensional map hopefully the
dimension is related to the approximate
run okay
let me skip this
and actually so this approach I just
described has a close connection to
diffusion process and damage reduction
there so for example if we if our data
as trajectories of us know has a
diffusion process we can use the
approach we described to generate
embeddings
of the state space to generate
embeddings of the state space and also
to identify Micah stable clusters which
are notions from again stochastic
processes okay
and
okay so another thing we try to work on
this again suppose that we're looking at
trajectories generated by an unknown
random walk okay and we try to use a
convex hull to approximate the state
space and back home as ho I mean that I
want to find a representative state such
that they are convex combination can
describe dynamics originated from other
states so this can be both down to a
summation of anunnaki factorization
problem and this is an interesting
experiment so we can show that by
analyzing traffic data from Manhattan
and try to approximate locations in
Manhattan City using a convex hull then
the vertices of the Congress house tend
to be landmarks of the city and they
actually carry a integral meaning about
what is the underlying dynamics so
finally we had an experiment together
with Steven to analyze trajectories of a
hurricane and the one can show that by
reducing the dimensionality of game
states using the embedding diffusion of
I here one can actually identify pair of
game states that have larger much larger
distance in their original form but they
are very close after embedding and the
approximately embedding and if we read
you can really look at the pair of game
States they actually have very
interesting physical meanings about the
current I would say like strategic home
state of the game okay so I don't have
time to talk about all this and so this
is a list of collaborators and students
and so there are a lot of open problems
in reinforcement learning to radically
how can we understand from statistical
and online learning
and also how to do the mention reaction
effectively while doing green for
learning so hopefully we can work
together and in da in the hours almost
regret guarantee one can okay okay so
first one way to do that is to Mattel
that matrix another way to do that is
suppose that we have kernel information
or your features is really about a
particular way to do regression over the
data point we have designated
intermediate the transition there okay
this case this mmm yes oh this is an
abstract way to write down the algorithm
but we don't have to so we don't really
have to do optimization here it has a
close one
okay maybe we'll take further questions
offline the interest of time and thank
the speaker again
[Applause]
[Music]